we're living in a fascinating time we're
living in a time where women have money
okay which is do you realize how new
that is right that's like 30 years old
or something and there's no blueprint
for how to operate and I think it's
really messing up the power dynamic like
the fact that I can pay my own bills
that's a big deal for me I thought that
making money was gonna solve all my
problems especially my relationship
problems because when I was in my 20s I
had to date guys that had money because
I didn't have any but now that I make my
own money
I felt like it opened up this whole new
pool of broke guys that I couldn't date
before so I've been doing that they're
much nicer and the last guy I dated I
paid for everything I paid for trips I
paid for dinners and now that I've sort
of been the man in the relationship now
that I've been in your shoes I now
understand why you guys hate us it's cuz
we owe you so much money and
something happens psychologically when
you start to pay for someone where you
start to hate them so to hate everything
about them you resent them you start
keeping score of everything they do one
day he came home he was drinking a
coconut water
it's like coconut water where did the
queen of England I better drink
out of the tap like a goddamn man how
about that I mean they nag you they
always need something from you you know
you'd be like you wanna go to dinner I'm
like you just ate yesterday do you have
a tapeworm what's the problem I feel
like I now understand why you guys are
we so disappointed in us too because
something happens when you start paying
for someone where you start to get these
high expectations for their behavior
like as soon as I started paying for him
I started expecting him to like do
chores out of nowhere like one night we
went to dinner I spent $200 on dinner
the next morning I woke up I was like
this is weird it's 8 a.m. and I don't
smell eggs
yeah chop chop mommy's hungry
[Music]
it's tricky I also started noticing all
these like unspoken rules that happen
with the expectations based on who pays
like the expectation if the man pays for
the woman is that she's gonna have sex
with you right but when I was paying for
the man the expectation was I am NOT
gonna have sex with you and we're gonna
stay up all night talking about my
dreams I'm gonna read some horoscopes
tonight and then I saw like all
the insidious like institutionalized
sexism like every time we would go to
dinner the waiter would automatically
give him the check and then he would
take it and then when the way to
relieve he would slide it over to me I
was like oh hell no if you take the
check you're paying you better find
yourself a Groupon real fast I also get
now why people stay in relationships too
long because money makes makes things
stickier like I feel like I stayed in
that relationship three months too long
just because I don't want to get a bad
return on my money because dating is
such a terrible investment which made me
think like I can't believe we just run
around spending money on relationships
that we don't know is gonna work out
it's a terrible investment I feel like
there should be some kind of insurance
in place to protect us like I feel like
dating should be like checking into a
hotel okay you and I are gonna start
dating as soon as we start dating you
have to put your credit card down three
months later if you want to break up
I'll be like all right well let's look
at your bill
yeah you owe me $3,200 or you can't
leave